[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
are going to be explaining every villain
in my hero academia thank you so much
for your support on our every critic
explained class 1-a video and on our
hero killer stain explained video you
guys requested it so in this video we
are going to be talking about some of
the coolest characters in the my hero
academia anime and manga while there are
certainly some cool hero characters out
there I was always intrigued by the
villains of my hero academia so I had a
great time making this video just a
quick warning there will be some manga
spoilers but I will do my best to give
you an explanation of the villain and
their quirks without revealing too much
about what ultimately happens to them in
the story and now if you're excited and
ready to go be sure to Detroit smash
that like button and if you're new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and click that notification bell in the
world of my hero academia the villains
are the people who decided to use their
perks not for helping others but for
their own ends armed with amazing powers
or quirks these criminals pose a serious
threat to society and they are a
constant thorn in the size of the
world's many heroes in this video we are
going to be listing all of the notable
lone wolf villains all of the members of
the notoriously go villain and members
of the 8th presets of death and of
course by notable villains I mean those
villains that we have enough information
on to actually talk about and jumping
right into the lone wolf villains we
have sludge introduced in the first
episode of the anime and the first
chapter of the manga the sludge villain
has a body that appears to be made of
mud and he is shown to be extremely
brutal and cruel his quirk turns him
into a shapeless monster made of mud and
because he doesn't appear to have any
joints or bones in his sludge form the
sludge villain is highly resistant to
physical attacks he is able to possess
the bodies of others and even use their
quirks by wrapping himself around them
although it apparently
at least 45 seconds for sludge to take
control of someone else's body
despite the amazing power of his Clerk
he was successfully taken out by all
night and next we have trapezius
headgear
he appears in episode 9 of the anime and
in Chapter 13 of the manga he is a
muscle-bound villain who is shown taking
a family hostage and acting in a very
cruel manner his quirk is an unnamed
strength-based quark and we can assume
that this villains quark gives him
superhuman strength and speed and we
know that he was strong enough that two
pro hero's Mount Lady and Tom we woods
could not take him down he is ultimately
taken down by all night with just one
misery smash chop proving that while
this villain is strong he is not in the
same league as all might and of course
the most notorious lone wolf villain
hero killers stain cheese oh man a
kabura better known as Spain is an
infamous villain known for killing prole
heroes staying is motivated by a purist
ideology which holds that modern society
has become corrupt as a result of faith
heroes who don't care about helping
others but are instead interested in
gaining money and power for themselves
his ultimate goal is to rid the world of
fake heroes and create a better society
where heroes are genuinely interested in
helping others and doing good as you
will see as this video goes on stain is
a very influential figure among the
villains of this world and his ideology
inspired many villains to follow in his
footsteps the name of his squirt is the
blood curdle and its type is emitter the
power of states quirk is too literally
paralyzed anyone whose blood he is able
to consume the length of the paralysis
depends on the blood type of each victim
and the maximum amount of time that the
paralysis can last is eight minutes
stained always carries a variety of
different blades with him so that he can
easily draw the blood of his opponents
and activate his quirk if you want to
know more about hero killer stain check
out our full video on him where we go in
much greater depth of
Stane as a character and about his
powers the link is in the description
and now we are going to move on to the
League of villain the most infamous
villain group in my hero academia whose
goal is to kill all might the one hero
considered to be the symbol of peace and
stability and to create a new society
that suits their own needs first we have
Tamara shigaraki she Guara Keys real
name is Peng Kojima and he is one of the
leaders of the League of villainous
although he did not create the League
and we will talk about the mastermind
behind the entire league a little bit
later she got aki is the acting leader
of the league of villains he is
determined to create a world without all
life the name of his quark is
disintegration its life is emitter and
it works on contact with his quark
shigaraki has the power to literally
destroy anything he lays his hands on
the destruction activates automatically
whenever he touches something with all
five of his fingers so in order to touch
anything that he doesn't want to destroy
shigaraki has to make sure that he
touches it with only a part of his hand
in his super villain outfit shigaraki
has 14 disembodied hands that are
holding different parts of his body
including a hand that covers his face
oddly enough she got a key called the
hand that covers his face the father and
he has a strange and obsessive
attachment to it
Shigure aki appears to be a deeply
disturbed individual he does not value
the lives of others and he is prepared
to kill you a student and innocent
civilians in order to get what he wants
there is an interesting aspect of
shigaraki backstory that might explain a
lot about his behavior as a child he is
said to have been in an incident in
which he needed help but no one who
passed by helped him because they just
assumed that helping him was the job of
heroes he was finally saved not by a
hero but by the founder of the league of
villains who then takes shigaraki under
his wing and grooms him into becoming a
villain this incident is interesting
commentary on the society of my bureau
academia in a world where heroes are
expected to do all the good deeds and to
save people normal people no longer take
responsibility for anything that is
going
around them next we have kudo Giri the
second-in-command of the legal villian
his name means black fog and it is an
appropriate name since his quirk makes
him appear as if he was completely made
of black fog who do get he tends to
speak like a proper gentleman and when
he is out and about on a normal day he
tends to dress in a suit and tie however
when he is doing villainous things he
appears to wear nothing at all and so he
looks like a massive black mist with
long yellow eyes the name of his quirk
is warpgate
its type is emitter and it works the
long range his quirk is classified as an
extremely rare type of work and it
allows you to get it to create portals
out of the black fog that surrounds him
and to teleport object and people to
another location or to bring object and
people from another location to his
current one he can use the fog to hide
his own body but his body is always in
there somewhere
so his opponents can find it they can
potentially take him down before he uses
his quirk the only limitation of this
powerful and extremely cool quirk is
that he must know the exact location in
which the portals are going to open so
for example he cannot simply choose to
teleport to all my bedroom and kill him
in his sleep unless he knows where
exactly that bedroom is located kudo
kitty is definitely an impressive
villain with a very cool quirk and I
think I have the perfect waifu for this
guy shadow we were from sheera then we
had gear on he is a broker and scout who
looks for new villains and tries to get
them to join the league of villain his
primary concern is making money and he
isn't interested in the well-being of
other people nearly as much as he is
interested in profit he is known for
always smoking a cigarette and having a
smirk on his face his quirk is still
unknown to us
but we do know that Gearin has
exceptional business savvy and close
connections to the criminal underworld
which makes him a formidable foe for any
hero next we have no move no mu is a
huge muscular creature with a beak
shaped mouth sharp teeth and a large
brain that is located on the outside of
his head no mu is
to be an artificial human which means
that he was once a regular person who
was experimented on by the League of
villains these experiments spliced his
genes with the genes of multiple other
people turning him into a mindless slave
who only follows orders despite this he
is extremely powerful and ruthless in
carrying out the orders given to him and
due to the experimentation conducted on
him he is actually capable of using two
different works the first work is shock
absorption which allows him to absorb
the force of any and all attacks coming
his way although there is a limit to how
much damage he can sustain the second
quirk is super regeneration as the name
suggests this quirk allows no mood to
quickly recover from any damage
sustained to his body
and even to regenerate entire limbs
normal was created for the specific
purpose of destroying all life and his
powers are set to rival all minds it is
important to know that there are
multiple normal or artificial humans
that have been created by the League of
villains but the gnomon that face off
against all might at the usj appears to
be the strongest artificial human that
we have encountered to date and now for
the real leader of the league of
villains the boss of all bosses a man
known as all for one all for one was
once the most powerful villain in all of
Japan and all might greatest enemy his
true identity is a mystery for most of
the series he is known for wearing a
dark and frankly pretty epic mask that
reminds me of Darth Vader and much like
Darth Vader beneath the mask he appears
to have a severely scarred and
disfigured face and breathing tubes can
be seen sticking out of his neck
implying that he was gravely injured at
some point in his life he is portrayed
as an evil mastermind who creates
elaborate flossin scheme and is able to
manipulate many different people to do
his bidding
just like his villain name the name of
his quark is all for one and this quark
allows its user to steal the quirks of
others and use them himself this in
itself sounds pretty incredible but on
top of that all
also allows its user to transfer the
stolen quirks on to other people
the unfortunate individuals who have
their quirks stolen by all-4-one are
left in a vegetative state similar to a
coma that is pretty brutal in and of
itself but in addition to that some
people who receive a stolen work as a
result of all-4-one are unable to handle
them and they themselves become mindless
creatures capable of nothing but
following orders just like no move and
if that wasn't enough the user of all
for one can combine multiple stolen
works in one person in order to create a
more powerful super Kirke that would
never have occurred naturally for these
reasons I think that all for one is
probably the most dangerous quirk in the
entire world of my hero academia and now
we're going to be looking at the
Vanguard action squad which is a group
of new recruits affiliated with the
League of villains who are considered to
be an elite villain fighting force the
Vanguard action squad was born when
Dobby and himiko toga are inspired by
the ideology of Spain to join the league
of villains because they mistakenly
believe that stain was himself a member
of the league starting off with Dobby
after the public learned about Spain and
his philosophy Dobby was one of the
people who was inspired to follow insane
footsteps and to finish what Spain had
started he joined the League of villains
in the belief that Spain was affiliated
with them and he has a very interesting
appearance as large portions of his skin
are dark purple and seemed to be sown to
the rest of his body with stitches
similar to depictions of the
Frankenstein monster Dobby is calm
confident and he doesn't let anyone mess
with him Dobby has a fire based quirk
which allows them to generate powerful
dark flames that he can then use to
destroy his enemies his chosen a villain
name is Dobby which means cremation and
this of course makes sense when we
consider his deadly fire based quirk
next we have he Miko's toga
just like Dobby Tolga joined the legal
villains in order to follow in the foot
sets of her idol save although her
ultimate goal is to make the world a
better place in the way that stain had
intended she exhibits signs of being
mentally unstable or younger at in anime
speak she smiled and laughed
sadistically as she destroys her enemies
and she appears cheerful even in the
face of imminent danger the name of her
quark is transformed and its type is
quite obviously transformation togas
quark allows her to change her
appearance in order to look and sound
like a completely different person if
she is able to consume enough of that
person's blood on top of that if she
holds her breath and clears her mind she
can actually appear invisible to her
opponents during a battle she carries a
pocket knife that allows her to drain
the blood of her opponent so that she
can use her quark and she also carries a
blood draining machine on her back that
lets her drain the blood quickly while
she is not a physically powerful villain
her power rank is only a one out of five
she has excellent reflexes and makes up
for what she lacks in power with her
agility speed and stealth then we have
spinner this villains unique physical
features make him easily recognizable in
a crowd he has a distinctly reptilian
appearance and the face of a giant
lizard as yet another villain who was
greatly inspired by stain spinners masks
and clothing appear to be designed to
mimic what stained himself wore the most
interesting part about him is his
strange weapon a giant makeshift sword
made up of all sorts of different
smaller blades despite its size spinner
is able to use the sword with
exceptional speed which makes a thing
that his quirk could be related to
superhuman reptilian strength
reminiscent of the powers that lizard
from spider-man possesses next we have a
villain called twice an intriguing and
highly contradictory villain twice as
real name is Jin bubai guada although he
gives great importance to understanding
one's own identity he actually suffers
from an identity crisis himself the name
of his squirt is double
it's type is emitter and it works on
contact this quirk enables twice to
create clothes of himself or others by
touching them he has previously used
this power to clone himself over and
over again in order to create an army of
clones but because each clone retains
the exact same personality as the
original the clones could not determine
who was the real twice and they turned
on each other the current twice cannot
be sure whether he was the original or
whether he is simply one of his own
clone whenever one of the clones he
creates with his quirk is destroyed it
dissolves into a dark liquid then we
have muscular muscular is a muscle-bound
villain with a distinctive scar on his
face and a prosthetic eye he is sadistic
and violent and he takes pleasure in
killing people including innocent
civilians
although his physical power is very
impressive his intelligence level leaves
much to be desired he scores a 5 out of
5 for both power and speed but only a 1
out of 5 for intelligence the name of
this quirk is muscle augmentation its
type is transformation and it works at
close range
his quirk enables muscular to transform
or augments his muscle fibers in order
to become both stronger and faster this
quirk is incredibly powerful when it
comes to physical strength it allows him
to smash rocks to bit and he was even
able to take the force of that whose
100% the Troy smash without suffering
any significant injuries he lost his eye
in a battle against two pro heroes while
trying to attack a village in the battle
muscular actually murdered both heroes
but after the battle he was too injured
to continue attacking the village next
is mustard a teen villain with a rather
unique look
mustard is known for wearing a school
uniform along with a gas mask and a
green army helmet he carries a revolver
pistol as a weapon and he isn't afraid
to use it
his quirk is referred to as sleep gas
its type is emitter and it works a long
range this quirk enables mustard to
create a gas that puts people to sleep
he is able to control the gas and he can
also sense the movement of anyone who is
located inside the zone where the gas
has spread as he is not immune to the
effects of his own quirk mustard has to
wear a gas mask and if he himself is
incapacitated then the gas will
disappear
his name is likely a reference to
mustard gas a deadly chemical weapon
first used by the German army in World
War one the military helmet that mustard
wears could be based on German military
helmet then we have mod named Magnus
real name is Kenji Hickey sheep and he
is easily recognized by his large list
and long red hair known for his
ruthlessness and cruelty magnet was a
hardened criminal who committed multiple
robberies and murders before joining the
league of villains the name of his quirk
is magnetism and this quirk enables
magnet to magnetize everyone within a
four and a half meter radius from where
he is standing he uses the magnetic
properties of his work to manipulate the
movement of his opponent either their
entire bodies or a specific part of
their body
men and women appear to have different
magnetic poles according to the rules of
this work and if he magnetizes two
people of the same gender magnet can
actually make them repel each other with
great force he is unable to use his work
on himself but even without his four
magnet is extremely skilled in
hand-to-hand combat next is a villain
known as moonfish one of the creepiest
villains in the entire series moonfish
is believed to be a brutal criminal who
was sentenced to death but managed to
escape from death row he wears some sort
of S&M straitjacket outfit and his mouth
is forced to stay open with metal clamps
he is obsessed with meat and flesh
especially the flesh of his opponent and
he is known for talking to himself like
a madman his quirk is referred to as
dental manipulation and the clerk allows
him to transform his teeth into
extremely strong and sharp blades that
can be used both to attack opponents and
to help him move
out of the way of oncoming attacks last
but not least for the vanguard we have
mr. compressed he is said to be one of
the most intelligent villains in the
world and I personally find him to be
one of the most intriguing villains
because of his cool mask and outfit is
interesting quirk and his eccentric
personality the name of his quirk is
compressed it's pipe is emitter and it
works on contact this quirk enables mr.
compressed to literally shrink or
compress everything within a certain
physical zone into a small marble mr.
compress can track people inside these
marbles and render them powerless and he
is also able to quickly turn everything
inside the marbles back to its normal
size when he wants to aside from his
squirt he has epic acrobatic skills
impressive speed and as I mentioned
already he is an extremely intelligent
individual the final group of villains
that we are going to be talking about in
this video are known as the eight
precepts of death and they're the newest
villain in the series they are
affiliated with the Yakuza or the
Japanese mafia and they are first
introduced in chapter 115 of the manga
they are known for wearing creepy yet
captivating plague masks first we have
overhaul overhaul is the leader of the
eight precepts of death he is also known
as Chucky and he is a major germaphobe
to put it mildly
he hates dirty places anything that
everyone around him is sick and filthy
his goal is to become the undisputed
ruler of the criminal underworld and he
doesn't hesitate to destroy anyone who
stand in his way
whether they are heroes or villains the
name of his quirk is overhaul its type
is emitter and it works on contact this
powerful quirk allows overhaul to
disassemble anything he touches only to
reassemble it again later when he uses
it against an opponent the opponent will
experience incredible pain and become
incapacitating but their body parts will
later be reassembled with all of their
past injuries and illnesses cured using
his quirk appears to take a physical
toll on overhaul he developed a rash and
itch
which might feed into his irrational
fear of illnesses next we have Kronos
faces overhauls faithful assistant
chrono stasis has an unnamed stealth
based quirk he is capable of moving
around undetected and launching sneak
attacks against his opponent which we
can assume is a direct result of his
mysterious quirk he carries a dart
firing pistol that seems to have the
ability to disrupt the works of his
opponent now the meaning of the word
chrono stasis is a temporal illusion
which makes our brain think that a
certain event is taking longer than it
really is for example when you're in
class and staring at the clock waiting
for class to end what time seems to go
slower than usual you are experiencing
chrono stasis so I wonder could his name
be a hint that chrono stasis possesses a
quirk that can slow down time this would
certainly explain his health and if true
it would be one of the absolutely
coolest quirks in my hero academia and
finally we have mimicked the general
manager of the eight presets of death
and a loyal follower of overhaul mimic
has a quirk called mimicry and its type
is emitter this quirk gives him the
ability to possess objects and to
control them the size of an object he
can possess is said to be no bigger than
a refrigerator but the quirk boosting
drug known as trigger allows him to
possess much larger object and even an
entire basement floor and these are the
three most notable members of the eight
precepts of that but there are other
members as well although the information
we have on them so far is limited if you
would like to see a special video about
the eight precepts of death in the
future as we learn more about them be
sure to let me know down below and that
is it for this video guys thank you so
much for watching and thanks to Sol
mock-up from our discord server for
helping me out with this video I know
that we covered a lot of villains in
this video but I hope that having them
all here in one place will be useful for
you and if you want to see any of the
villains described in greater
detail like we did with hero killer
Spain let me know down in the comments
if you enjoyed this video and want to
see more my hero academia videos be sure
to 100% that Troy smash that like button
and if you are new to the channel be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification valve if you'd like to chat
with us about anime on a daily basis you
can join our discord server the link is
in the description and until next time
see us space Cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]